Борис Джонсон, якого українці охрестили Борисом Джонсонюком
за його допомогу Україні, від сьогодні вже більше не прем’єр Великобританії.
У своїй прощальній промові він назвав ЗСУ героїчними.
Через ці лаковані чорні двері незабаром увійде нова прем'єр-міністерка
- щоб познайомитися з фантастичною групою державних діячів.
Це люди, які організували швидке постачання озброєння героїчній українській армії.
Це те, що могло допомогти змінити курс найбільшої за 80 років війни в Європі.
І я знаю, що Ліз Трасс і цей розумний консервативний уряд зробить усе,
щоб допомогти людям подолати цю кризу. Ця країна подолає її, і ми переможемо.
І якщо Путін думає, що він може перемогти шантажем та булінгом британців,
то він глибоко помиляється.
Борис Джонсон у променях сонця залишає Даунінг-стріт 10.
А тим часом всесвітньовідомий мешканець прем'єрської резиденції кіт Ларрі
вже вийшов на ґанок зустрічати нову господиню - Ліз Трасс.
Ще під час передвиборчої кампанії за посаду лідера консерваторів вона обіцяла,
що стане найбільшим другом України, наслідуючи Бориса Джонсона,
і буде повністю віддана тому, щоб Путін зазнав поразки в Україні.
У багатьох своїх промовах щодо війни Росії в Україні Ліз Трасс вживає саме цю фразу:
…щоб Україна перемогла.
…Україна переможе.
Ліз Трасс - 47 років. Вона стала третьою прем’єркою в історії Великобританії.
Її називають "залізною леді 2.0", натякаючи на її намагання наслідувати Маргарет Тетчер
- ікону британських консерваторів. Сама ж Ліз Трасс відхрещується від цих порівнянь,
хоча й захоплюється Маргарет Тетчер та її політикою.
Менше податків і соцвиплат - натомість більше підприємницької свободи
та вільної торгівлі. Таких поглядів дотримується Ліз Трасс.
Під час своєї урядової кар’єри вона була і міністеркою довкілля,
і міністеркою юстиції, і міністеркою зовнішньої торгівлі.
А рік тому стала головною дипломаткою Великобританії.
Як міністерка закордонних справ саме вона, зокрема, контролювала
запровадження санкцій проти оточення російського президента Володимира Путіна,
а також працювала разом із союзниками, щоб надати Україні
більше зброї та гуманітарної допомоги.
Ми повинні переконатися, що хоробрий український народ має зброю,
необхідну для захисту. Великобританія була першою європейською країною,
яка надіслала зброю в Україну, а Чехія була першою країною,
яка надіслала в Україну танки.
Разом ми навчаємо українських бійців завдяки британській військовій тренувальній команді.
Ми також обговорили важливість відбудови України та плану Маршалла,
який підтримує вільний світ, щоб відбудувати цю життєздатну країну.
Ми повинні бути готові до довготривалої підтримки України,
тому що ми віддані захисту свободи та демократії. Зараз не час заспокоюватися.
Не повинно бути розмов про припинення вогню чи заспокоєння Путіна.
Нам потрібно переконатися, що Україна переможе і що Росія відійде.
І що ми більше ніколи не побачимо такої російської агресії.
Ще в липні президент України Володимир Зеленський висловлював занепокоєння,
що наступник Джонсона може зменшити підтримку України.
Нині ж Зеленський більш оптимістичний і розраховує на щиру співпрацю.
Вже чекаю, коли можна буде продовжити нашу співпрацю з Борисом у його новому статусі.
І не менше чекаю початку співпраці з новим премʼєр-міністром Великої Британії
пані Ліз Трасс. Ми в Україні добре її знаємо - вона завжди була на світлій стороні
європейської політики. І я вірю, що разом ми зможемо зробити ще дуже багато
для захисту наших народів і для провалу всіх російських деструктивних зусиль.
Головне - зберігати нашу єдність, а це обовʼязково буде.
У Москві ж протягом останніх місяців дуже зневажливо говорили про Ліз Трас.
Міністерство закордонних справ Росії відкрито глузувало з неї через географічні помилки.
Найбільш напруженим був візит Трасс до Москви у лютому за два тижні до початку війни Росії проти України.
Очільник російського МЗС Сергій Лавров назвав їхню розмову
діалогом між глухим і німим.
Нині, зазначили у Кремлі, вони теж не можуть сподіватися на щось позитивне.
У найближчій перспективі ми не очікуємо якихось змін.
Не хотілося б казати, що ці зміни можуть статися на гірше.
Адже ще гірше уявити собі складно. Але цього виключати не можна.
Експерти ж прогнозують, що нова прем’єрка не буде послаблювати тиск на Кремль
і продовжуватиме підтримувати Україну попри енергетичну кризу в Європі.
Я б очікував продовження політики жорсткості щодо вторгнення Росії в Україну.
Я не бачу, щоб ця позиція змінилася, хоча буде дуже цікаво спостерігати,
як розвиватиметься громадська думка, коли витрати на війну почнуть впливати
на гаманці людей. Я очікую, що люди й надалі будуть солідарними з Україною,
але це може призвести до цікавого компромісу для уряду.
Жодних змін щодо України не буде. Цілком очевидно, що в національних інтересах Британії
- переконатися, що ми намагаємося тримати Росію в страху.
Трасс, мабуть, навіть більш жорстка, ніж Джонсон, щодо Китаю.
Тому ми можемо побачити деяку різницю в тональності.
Але в іншому різниця у зовнішній політиці не дуже велика.
Питання для Трасс полягатиме в тому, чи зможе вона продовжити цей конфлікт
з ЄС через Північну Ірландію та при цьому зберегти дружбу - так звані особливі відносини зі США.
Зрештою, експерти переконані, що позиція Трасс щодо Росії та її повномасштабного вторгнення в Україну
буде й надалі безкомпромісною і навіть більш категоричною,
ніж у її колишнього боса Бориса Джонсона.
Володимир Путін не просто націлився на Україну у своїй жахливій гібридній війні.
Він намагається змусити нас платити викуп, використовуючи голод
і російську енергію як зброю. Він робить ставку на те, що вільний світ
втомиться від його агресії. Але ми не втомилися і ми ніколи не зможемо втомитися,
захищаючи свободу та демократію, і ми покажемо це, роблячи все можливе,
щоб Україна перемогла.
Росію потрібно притягнути до відповідальності за цю жахливу війну,
розв’язану в Україні. Я хочу чітко пояснити, що ми сповнені рішучості надати Україні
необхідну підтримку в довгостроковій перспективі, як би довго не тривала ця війна,
тому що це життєво важливо не лише для української свободи та демократії,
але й для всієї нашої свободи та демократії, щоб Україна перемогла.
Українці ж кажуть, що сумуватимуть за Джонсоном і покладають надії
на Трасс та її щиру підтримку.
Мені шкода, що Джонсон іде. Зі сльозами на очах я про це говорю.
Але щодо України я не очікую від неї якихось негативних дій чи рішень,
вона надійно підтримує Україну. Я до неї дуже позитивно ставлюсь.
Я дуже сподіваюся, що вона буде все ж таки продовжувати політику Бориса Джонсона
і дуже сподіваємося, що буде підтримувати Україну.
Її політика від Джонсона щодо України ні чим не відрізняється, а це для нас великий плюс.
6 років тому Ліз Трасс несподівано для багатьох підтримала членство Великобританії
у Європейському Союзі. Тоді вона називала Brexit "потрійною трагедією:
більше правил, більше форм і більше затримок під час торгівлі з ЄС".
Але потім кардинально змінила свої погляди і підтримала жорсткий курс Джонсона на Brexit.
Українці сподіваються, що таких різких розворотів щодо підтримки України
у Ліз Трасс не буде.